in spain a searing heatwave has fared a  series of devastating wildfires some 30  or so are still burning firefighters  struggling to get them under control and  it's a particular problem here in the  northwest of the country where we are in  the town of zamora and in the mountains  around this town  tens of thousands of acres have been  burned two people have been killed  thousands of people have been evacuated  and the spanish prime minister has  warned that there is worse to come for  this region as temperatures climb again  many communities remain evacuated as  they watch those temperatures increase  these very hot very dry conditions  all being made worse by climate change  feeding these deadly fire events and  causing misery for this country and  across europe  you